there are so many stories of strange
creatures cryptids and terrifying
monsters from all around the world
i've always wanted to make a series
devoted to individual countries so
welcome to the strange creatures of
sweden
many of the creatures that appear today
will also be very common in other
scandinavian countries so you can look
at today's episode as a scandinavian
special
before we go any further a quick word
from today's awesome sponsor hellofresh
nothing really beats a home-cooked meal
but deciding what to eat buying the
ingredients preparing and cooking the
meal for those with a busy schedule can
be difficult to do several times a week
with hellofresh you can have a meal kit
that includes fresh ingredients and
cooking instructions sent directly to
your door
simply follow the instructions provided
and you have access to all sorts of
tasty meals within 30 minutes less time
than you'd spend in the grocery store
each week there are new recipes to
choose from with a low-carb low-fat and
vegetarian options if needed
the meal kits are sent in almost
entirely recyclable packaging so you can
even reduce your carbon footprint
so i've been using hellofresh for a few
weeks now and i've been extremely
pleased with what i received and the
amount of time i've been able to save
some of my favorite meals so far were
the teriyaki chicken with rice the honey
roasted duck with mashed potatoes and
the spicy creamy cajun pasta
you may be surprised to know that i'm no
gordon ramsay but these meals look and
taste great you also don't have to be a
michelin star chef to make them
so if you'd like to try hello fresh for
yourself you can visit
hellofresh.com and use code
mythology14 to receive 14 free meals as
well as free shipping so give it a try
and let me know which meals are your
favorite
we begin with the not so pleasant draga
the drago are animated corpses or
revenants that can be found in burial
mounds guarding treasure step into the
wrong tomb or try and steal something
shiny and you may wake a drogo or two in
swedish they are simply referred to as
drag which means someone pale and
dim-witted who drags themselves along
they are also described as corporeal
ghosts and vampires
the zombie comparison can be made as it
said you can tell when a drago is near
because the smell of decay is unbearable
their appearance is grotesque and
necrotic
at times they can be gaunt with exposed
and broken bones
towards the end of the 19th century they
were also considered a type of vampire
not because of the need to feed off
others to sustain themselves but because
their attacks could turn their victims
into their own kind
there are brief mentions of outbreaks
and epidemics in the old sagas as well
as being super strong they could
shape-shift control the weather and even
invade someone's dream leaving behind a
cursed object ensuring the victim's bad
fortune and even death
all of this makes being hunted by a
draga a very unpleasant experience
the skog's roar in swedish or the holder
in other parts of scandinavia is a type
of forest nymph often referred to as the
mistress of the forest
this entity is known for its seductive
but also deadly nature
she takes the form of a petite and
beautiful woman with a kind and friendly
demeanor
on they appear rather normal but from
behind they have a large hollow chasm in
their back as well as a tail
those unfortunate enough to interact
with these forest nymphs are never the
same many are simply never seen again
and the ones who do return are said to
be a shell of themselves an introvert or
a hermit those who lay with the
scotsuroa are said to leave behind their
souls for her keeping
one of the more disturbing sets of
creatures on today's list is the myelin
these are reanimated corpses or spirits
of children who had passed away
they are forced to roam the earth until
their dying wish has been fulfilled
normally this means the desire for a
proper burial these spirits can range
from young children to newborns and even
unborn children which makes this legend
even more disturbing the myelin exists
when a mother kills an unwanted child
and hides her crime they can be heard at
night singing their horrifying song
revealing their mother's crime to all
those who will listen
as many of these murders happened
shortly after birth these children were
never baptized or given a proper burial
and thus according to the church they
could never rest
the way to appease them is by giving
them a name finding their corpse and
burying them in holy soil
because of the violent nature of their
deaths the myelin were feared and
considered vengeful spirits
if you were chosen by a myelin to help
find their body and bury them
you had no real choice
failing to do so would result in your
death
the nekken were water spirits that lured
children and women down rivers and lakes
with enchanting songs played on a violin
they often appeared as a man with a
violin but it's thought that they had no
true shape or form they could shapeshift
into a box of treasure floating on the
water's surface
a beautiful woman or even an animal a
common form was a horse which is why
they may be referred to as brook horse
or river horse
the most common form the neck and spirit
takes in sweden is as a man playing a
musical instrument who also happens to
be naked sometimes
not all neck and were malevolent or evil
as there are stories of them living on
land and integrating into society for
short periods of time before eventually
returning to the water
there are also tales of nekken teaching
others how to play the violin or fiddle
but some are driven completely insane by
the music
the evil neckern would target unbaptized
children and pregnant women with their
songs but they would also drown young
men as well so i guess no one was safe
the song played is so enchanting that
you forget where you are before you
realize you're in the water about to
drown yourself
similar to creatures such as the
grendilo or the kelpie these tales were
likely created to keep children away
from dangerous rivers and lakes
the mare ormara is an entity that has
appeared throughout europe under many
different names it is a spirit that
rides on your chest while you sleep and
brings you nightmares a sleep paralysis
monster
the mara would ride horses during the
night leaving the owners confused as to
why they were tired and sweaty in the
morning once the horses were exhausted
they would find sleeping men entangle
them with their hair and begin to invade
their dreams until they became
nightmares
as well as women they could also take
the form of any animal they desire
making them rather tricky to identify
for our last set of creatures i will
pass you over to today's guest artist
and swedish native
mando who can share some of her own
experiences and stories
hi my name is mando and i'm an artist
and youtuber from northern sweden i've
been on this channel before as an artist
and animator but today i'm here to talk
to you about my local mythology the
winters here are long and dark so it's
understandable that the people living
here have been doing their best to
please the spirits of nature
my grandmother have told me so many
stories one is about a magic you can do
with a ball of yarn and she always just
mentioned it so for this very video i
decided to ask my grandmother what is up
with the ball of yarn and it's about a
creature called badan it goes by many
names troll hair milk hair in english it
is known as a troll cat and you make
this creature with nine types of yarn
blood from your left pinky and when you
say a spell your bottom will come alive
and it will roll off to steal milk and
fortune from your neighbors but coming
from a long line of farmers the creature
i feel most closely connected to is the
witra the stories differ depending on
where you're from but here they are
described much like humans living like
my grandmother did when she was a child
self sustainably and farming their
critters they can choose if they want to
be seen by humans or not and at least
here they are described to be as really
really small apparently i saw one when i
was a child a pale woman looking at me
from behind the leg of a chair you're
not really supposed to tell anyone if
you saw them though so
i hope it's okay you don't want to get
on the vitra's bad side anytime you pour
water or something outside or if you're
out camping and you pee outside you have
to warn the vitra because who would want
to get that in on their head you know if
they like you they can help you but if
you anger them they can cast sickness on
you my mother experienced this once she
was camping with a friend and when they
had set up camp they put all their
belongings in a bag inside another bag
inside a backpack and hung it high in a
tree to protect it from wild animals
that evening when they went to sleep
they opened some bottles but they could
never find the bottle caps again no
matter how much they searched the next
morning when my mother woke her eyes
were itchy and swollen and she said they
were full of sand as if she hadn't slept
in a long time her friend was already up
so she went outside to look for her and
when she saw her her face were
completely red as if she was burned by
the sun so they packed up and went home
and as they were unpacking in my
grandmother's kitchen suddenly they
found the bottle caps they had been
pressed into each other so hard they
couldn't be separated and they found
them inside the bag inside the bag
inside the backpack and they could not
figure out how they could have ended up
there but my grandmother looked at them
and she said were there little trails on
the ground and they said yeah there was
some animal trails there but my
grandmother said it was bitter trails
and you have angered the vitra and they
obviously messed with you with their
bottle caps make up that story what you
will in today's day and age it's not
many who believes in or even knows about
the vitra but my grandmother have taught
me to respect them and i still do that
anytime i pour something out i say watch
out people of the underworld better be
on the safe side
a huge thanks to mando for the artwork
in this video and especially for sharing
her own stories and experiences with us
if you would like to see more of mando
she does have her own channel called
heart full of forest which focuses on
art nature culture and minimal living
i'll link one of mando's videos down
below so you can check it out
hopefully you've enjoyed this video if
you'd like to see this series continue
then let me know which country you want
to see next
as always
i've been your host
mythology and fiction explained
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you